La importancia de la computación cuántica está tanto subestimada
como enormemente sobrevaluada al mismo tiempo.
Aunque no reemplazará a las computadoras convencionales,
la innovación cuántica representa un nuevo paradigma computacional.
Las computadoras cuánticas pueden trabajar en conjunto con la infraestructura
informática actual para resolver problemas complejos que antes se consideraban
poco prácticos o imposibles.
Esto puede ser un cambio de paradigma.
Por ejemplo, la dificultad de factorizar números grandes
en sus factores primos es la base de la
criptografía moderna. Para el tamaño de números usados en la criptografía pública
de clave privada moderna, este cálculo llevaría
más de 300 billones de años a la computadora convencional más rápida.
Para una computadora cuántica a gran escala que trabaje
con el algoritmo de Shor, este cálculo podría tomar segundos.
Problemas complejos como este existen en todas las industrias.
Las aplicaciones potenciales de la computación cuántica
son vastas.
Las computadoras cuánticas ya están creciendo en tamaño
y capacidad,
mientras apuntamos a abordar problemas más complejos.
Desde 2016, IBM ha puesto las computadoras cuánticas al alcance del público
a través de un sitio web con una interfaz gráfica que
se parece a una partitura musical,
y el kit de desarrollo de software Qiskit,
que permite a los usuarios programar computadoras cuánticas.
Científicos dentro y fuera del mundo corporativo
están realizando experimentos
a través de portales similares. Están explorando enfoques para problemas de química
y aprendizaje automático, intentando descubrir
qué tipo de preguntas pueden hacer
y cómo van a formular esas preguntas
cuando la tecnología esté más avanzada. Ahora es el
momento adecuado para que los líderes empresariales se preparen
para lo cuántico. Las condiciones están dadas para experimentar
y expandir esta tecnología fundamentalmente nueva.
Las organizaciones que busquen estar a la
vanguardia de este cambio transformacional
obtendrán una ventaja competitiva. Esta formación
te preparará para comenzar tu camino cuántico.